- Well if it isn't Mr. Stanley.
- Carl.
(dramatic music playing)
- You need to find your
own troubled white boy.
- I was here foist.
(dramatic music continues)
Copycat.
(Key screams)
- Ladies and gentlemen, please
turn off your cell phones
and enjoy our production
of "Lunch with Greatness".
- My, my, my.
(audience claps)
What a beautiful day
in Montgomery, Alabama.
I swear the sun is so
hot, I nearly melted.
- Indeed, Dr. King.
But I suspect we didn't meet here to talk
about the weather.
- Indeed, brother Malcolm.
Unless of course we articulate
that the sun in this
country shines brighter
on some than it does on others.
- Yes, but when the sun does shine on us
it is growing the seeds of revolution.
- [Audience Member] Amen.
- Yes, brother Malcolm.
- I see your point brother Malcolm.
But do not those same seeds
need to be watered with love.
(audience saying mhmm)
- Well, I suppose that is the
subject of some discussion,
Dr. King.
- And I am all for
discussion Brother Malcolm.
Unless of course the words devolve
into proclamations of hate.
(audience clapping)
- For is that not why we
are here today, Dr. King,
to discuss?
(fly buzzing)
- Yes, brother Malcolm.
And I am confident that as we discuss-
- We are going to discuss
it, and discuss it,
until I say
that our people have never resorted
to violence before.
The white man gave them no choice
but to pay him back in the
only currency he understands.
(audience clapping)
- Brother Malcolm.
Is that what you really
have to say at this point
in our lunch?
- Indeed, Dr. King.
Because we didn't land on Plymouth Rock.
Plymouth Rock landed on us.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Okay, well, yes.
All right.
Yeah, I've heard you say that before.
I don't know why we're
talking about rocks,
when in fact it is the flesh
and the bone and the dreams.
I have a dream that's someday
our children will be judged
by the content of their character,
not by the color of their skin.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Yep, yep, yep.
Same for me.
In fact, I believe that
one day a black man will
become the president of the
United States of America.
(audience clapping)
Hopefully for eight years.
(audience clapping and cheering)
Obama 2020.
(audience continues clapping)
- Oh, of course he is.
Of course he is.
That's a given, right?
That's a given, you know.
I mean, but in order to get there
isn't he going to need the help
of our strong, beautiful black women?
(audience clapping and cheering)
Respect the sisters.
Gotta respect the sisters.
(audience continues clapping and cheering)
- As Wesley Snipes said in "Passenger 57",
"Always bet on black".
(audience clapping and cheering)
- The west side, here's the west side.
(audience continues clapping and cheering)
- Oh man, I really had
to get outta the house.
- I'm just glad you came out.
- Appreciate it, man.
- For real.
- Yo, yo, yo.
Check this girl out, man.
She is fine.
- She aight.
- Really?
- Ay man, I am going
to go to the bathroom.
- Okay man.
See you in a minute.
- You know what?
I told myself this morning,
I wasn't gonna fall in love.
You went and made me break my only rule.
I'm gonna take that, right quick.
I am going to take that,
I'm going to use that.
Okay.
(Peele laughs)
- Oh, hey, what's up man?
Got her number, huh?
- Yeah.
Cheyenne.
- Oh, was that her name?
- Yeah, she was fly.
- That's the girl I was talking about.
- Oh.
Snap.
Are you serious?
- Yeah, dude.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
- It ain't no thing man.
Forget it, there's plenty of hotties here.
- I just thought you was
talking about somebody else.
- Check her out.
(dramatic music plays)
- I'm not a sports man, but I think me
and you could touch down later,
if you know what I'm saying?
(Peele laughs)
Am I being stupid?
But for real though.
Just gimme your number.
Whatever.
Thank you girl.
I'm gonna take that from you.
- How did you get over here so fast?
- Huh?
- Nothing.
It just seemed like you-
- [News Reporter] The death
toll has climbed to seven
the second day of the Texas riots.
- ****, that reporter is smokin' hot.
(dramatic music plays)
- What the (beep).
(door slams shut)
(papers rustling)
(dramatic music plays)
No.
(marker squeaking)
(Key sighs)
Yeah.
(dramatic music plays)
No.
- Hey baby.
- How are you...
How are you doing that?
- Honey, what's wrong?
- Baby, I love you.
I'm sorry.
I was out, I was looking
at other women tonight.
But you are all there is, all right?
I love you.
(eerie music playing)
(Peele scatting)
(Peele continues scatting)
(audience claps)
- [Announcer] And now ladies and gentlemen
the man you've been waiting
for, Mr. Michael Winslow.
- Go get 'em Winslow.
Bring the noise.
Another sold out night for
the Kings of Mouth-noise.
Can I tell you though, we
wouldn't have this audience
without Winslow.
Lucky for you, huh?
(Key scatting)
Man, those "Police Academy" fans,
look at all the T-shirts.
(Key continues scatting)
Six sequels.
Can you believe it?
Every sound effect this guy makes is
like a little tiny Mona Lisa
popping out of his mouth.
Have you ever heard him do the walking
through leaves in the fall?
(dramatic music plays)
(far away audience claps)
(door opens)
(door closes)
(faint footsteps)
(Key breathing heavy)
(Key making squeaking sound effect)
(Key making popping noise with tongue)
(Key swallowing)
(Peele scatting)
(Key makes machine whirring noise)
(Key mimics whip snapping)
(Peele screaming)
(Peele scatting in low tone)
(Peele mimics dramatic music)
(Key mimics swords hitting each other)
(Peele continues to mimic dramatic music)
(Key mimics metal rod shaking)
(Peele mimics dramatic music)
(Peele mimics nunchucks whooshing)
(Key mimics gunshot sound)
(Peele breathing heavy)
(heart beating)
(Key making beeping sound)
(Peele mimics sad music)
(Key continues making beeping sound)
(Key mimics flat line sound)
(Key mimics police sirens)
(fake police siren continues)
(upbeat hip-hop music playing)
- 'Scuse me.
Pardon me.
Hey player.
- How you doing man?
- Hey, can I make a request?
- For sure, man.
What are you looking for?
- Hey man, hook a brother
up with some old school.
- Oh yeah, all right.
Word, okay.
What you looking for?
Biggie, Tupac?
- Biggie, Tupac?
(Peele laughs)
Come on man.
That's too new.
I'm talking about that old school, man.
You know what I'm talking about?
- Oh, but I thought I did
man with like a Wu-Tang Clan?
(Peele scoffs)
- Wu-Tang Clan?
Come on man.
Those fools just came out.
Hook a brother up with
some of that old school.
- Okay.
What-
I don't what you looking for man.
What N.W.A?
- N.W.A?
Come on man.
What do I look like a kid out there?
Talking about the N.W.A
fo' shizzle my nizzle.
Criss cross applesauce.
Who's the boss?
Tony Danza at a loft.
I don't know it.
Alright.
I'm talking about that old school.
- Okay.
You know what?
That's my bad old man.
All right.
We gonna take it back.
I'm gonna bust out some
Run-D.M.C for you right now.
- Run-D.M.C?
(Peele snickering)
Come on man.
I don't know about none
of this Run-D.M.C a,
wouldn't want to be ya,
onomonopia.
Grab a donkey by the toe.
Give him gonorrhea.
I don't know it.
All right, all I know is some old school.
If you can't give it to me,
you can't give it to me.
- Come on man.
Run-D.M.C is old school.
Well can you name a group?
- You the DJ man.
I ain't trying to tell
you how to do your job.
- Grandmaster Flash.
- Oh man, Grandmaster Fla-
You soundin' like a kid yourself.
Talking about Grandmaster
flash to the oom bop
the bippity boppity boo.
The don't stop the
boogie to the bang, bang
boogie the upchuck.
Why people talking about upchuck?
- Sugar Hill Gang.
- Brother, how we end up in Candy Land?
- You know what man, if
you want some old school
then you come back here
and find it yourself.
I'm going on break.
- All right then.
Get myself back here, right here.
See what's going on back here.
What we got?
Let see.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope
nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope nope.
Ah, there.
Now we talking.
(1920s style music playing)
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, there it is.
There it is.
Gonna pull it.
Think I can pull it, yeah I can pull it.
Yeah I can pull it.
- What the (beep) is happening?
(heavy rock music playing)
- Hey, far as I'm concerned,
this Saturday night
there's not even going to be a fight.
I'm gonna mercy kill this old man.
- Eric is very rude person.
But soon he will learn manners.
I will torture his body so that his soul
learns to be humble.
- I'm going to dance around
him while he's tryin'
to hit me with his cane.
Old man.
- God chose me for this fight.
God is the teacher.
Derek is the student, and
I am God's instrument.
When I squeeze your lungs,
Derek, and you beg me for life
then your heart will open up to the Lord.
- I'm going to knock him
out round one, *****.
Wait.
What did he say again?
He said God chose him?
That doesn't even make sense really.
- When you eat through plastic tube,
when you are paralyzed from neck down,
then your family will gather around
your hospital bed to sit (inaudible).
- Okay?
He know we just talking here, right?
I mean we just getting people interested
in the fight because, I'm sorry,
is this (beep) crazy?
- God's lessons are so beautiful.
- God's lessons are beautiful?
I'm sorry.
Who put this fight together?
This is ju-
If y'all got an actual
crazy person for me to fight,
well that's not fair to me or him.
(Key speaking in tongues)
What you mean you can't find him?
Well, where is he?
Yo man, where my manager at?
Steve, how's it-
(Key hits the floor)
(heavy rock music playing)
- Moving out?
Please, this is the worst possible time.
Please don't do this.
Babe?
(man sighs)
- Garbage.
- Huh?
- Can I take your garbage?
- Yeah, sure.
(Peele laughs)
- You know, I find the
more garbage in the can,
the better it feels to dump it all out.
I suppose that's why we let it get so full
in the foist place.
So we can start over.
(Peele snaps fingers)
- Here to fix the copier.
- Yeah.
Sure, sure.
Hey, how did you-
- Sometimes things ain't really broken.
It's the way we treat 'em
that needs to be fixed.
(magical tinkling)
(Key whistling)
(bird whistling)
(Key laughs)
- Who the hell are you guys?
- [Key And Peele] The
important question is
who are you, Steve?
(menacing music plays)
- Well, if it isn't Mr. Stanley.
- Carl.
- You need to find your
own troubled white boy.
(dramatic music plays)
- I was here foist.
Copycat.
(Key coughing)
- Sweep this.
(electricity buzzing)
(Key laughs)
(Peele snaps fingers)
- Uh oh.
(Peele laughs)
(electricity buzzing)
(paper rustling)
(paper whipping through air into bucket)
****!
Chesterfield.
(Key whistles)
(bird caws)
- [Key And Peele] There can
be only one magical negro.
(dramatic music continues playing)
(dramatic choir singing)
(electricity buzzing)
(Key and Peele yelling)
(loud explosion)
(car alarm beeping)
(glass falling)
(paper rustling)
- Good Lord.
Are you all right?
Well, I guess sometimes
things have to come apart
before we can put 'em back together again.
- Oh, you're a magical negro too.
- Who you call a negro, *****?
(upbeat music)